[Music]
mmm hello everyone
a lot of people joining in already hello
Remy goosh bean boy DJ troller og as
Lyra Zig and everyone else hello and we
are already starting with the first
tournament so the first tournament is
organized Friday sub 1700 arena but
someone mentioned in the comments that I
should named it meadow arena and the
next one will be made or arena where it
will be a sub 1700 and then we are going
into the main event which is just a
normal hour matter Friday arena to see
who will who will be able to win that
one
in the first one you know we already
have thirteen hundred and forty-four
players and in the big one nine hundred
and seventy seven players but I imagine
it will it will be even more when we
actually started so if you haven't
joined already the links to the both
tournaments will be in the description
below first link is I believe yeah sorry
the title is wrong it's just realised
that let me just change that real quick
yeah there we go I think that should
work I think the title should switch yes
the only true way to checkmate Boden is
Boden's mate so I can mention in the in
the video where I announced the this
tournament we are going to be showcasing
your games so I'm just gonna first try
some random games and then after after
we get closer of course the the finish
of the tournament we're gonna check out
all all the big ones hey Bruno pottery
which how you doing man I'm glad to see
you here no I don't think we have any
GM's signed as of yet but you never know
positive Marco horsemen all right so the
tournament starts in 1 minute and 20
seconds and let's enjoy some some
games thank thank you for the
contribution mr. mr. Chang Tao no sons
Aguirre yeah I was I was hoping to win
against them as well but they played
incredibly strong like it was a no no no
inaccuracies no mistakes just just a
really impressive game yeah no problem
man
no problem mark oh hey do I know Brooke
Monk
no I do not know Brooke Monk and I still
don't have I don't know how many viewers
will be today but as I don't have any
mods if any of you would like to mod
since you came so early you know apply
just right I would like to be a mod and
I will appoint you mod privileges like
maybe first first three people I guess
Final Fantasy is excellent so far but I
only played it like for a little bit so
I will still have to see how good is it
all right mr. stealing Apple you are you
are currently a moderator so enjoy that
make sure no one is no one is doing
anything weird in the chat and also mr.
Madden you were also a mod so there we
go you were a moderator and also mr.
let's see who wants to be a mod I prefer
I prefer people who have like at least a
photo next to their username so I you
know maybe maybe it just seems like
they're real people but yeah we have
three mods now so we're just gonna start
with that and we're starting off with
some of the games so let's let's check
out some of the games alright so this is
the first game we're at Chashma just
master nuba versus a finca 1600 circuit
that 1626 player against 1500 so let's
see let's enjoy some chests yes jelena
did give me a haircut there was it was
it was it was quite great i it's much
easier now then I didn't when I was you
know just go and go all over the place
mr. sock piano you joined by clicking on
the link in the description below but
the first tournament is only four
players rated below 1700 for everyone
asking both of the links to both
tournaments are in the description below
so what do we have here
efore d6 d3 f5 and Bishop g5 h6 so
already a very interesting very
interesting opening and just master noob
spending a lot of time on this one
tackling this h6 move already down a
queen h5 check that is that is good
stuff let's see how black deals with
this when will I fix the speakers I
don't know I don't know what's wrong
with them it just started at some point
and I've never been able to fix it well
I can't I will not be playing like I
said I will only be showcasing your
games so you guys will get a chance to
for everyone else that to check out your
game and it's less stressful now you
know playing on stream is very stressful
I might accept some challenges later
we'll see as it it's gonna be one hour
for this tournament two hours for that
tournament so I might I might do some
challenges after that we'll see I don't
know we'll see how it goes
yeah for the smaller tournament you have
to play at least 20 games and then you
will be able to I joined the tournament
20 rated blitz games and if you want to
join the the main event you have to have
played at least 100 games I thought that
way we were gonna eliminate cheaters
yeah I don't know that King and e7 is a
bit weird but white is burning a lot of
time trying to take advantage of that so
I don't know that anything can still
happen here
now King g8 opening
a discovery to the queen and black is
doing well oh wow
white tried something weird there and
then just blunder the Queen mr. Dylan
Lee says he uses an engine to play well
I'm sorry to inform you you will not
have a lot of fun on this tournament
since it's gonna be like that in the
future we're gonna have at least 100
games rated before you can actually join
so if there are any cheaters someone who
will use an engine you know we're not
gonna make it easy I'm gonna have to
make you play at least 100 games with
your new account and and so on there's
no good way to you know just make it
impossible for people to use engine so
we can just make it a little bit harder
yeah creation beer is great yeah what do
I say about the new BG vs. MVL game I
think it was a brilliant display of how
to use the night off but by Lubow really
really excellent stuff yeah the real
tournament does start in an hour I mean
this is also a real tournament but I
wasn't I wasn't planning on doing a sub
1,700 tournament but since so many of
you asked for it I decided yeah let's
let's do this one as well and see if if
it will be you know if people will come
and there's a lot more people on this
term and then on the main one so I think
we're gonna keep that format in the
future as well Davidge trope says if I
could answer a question yes yes I can no
since this is the first tournament there
are no prizes as leaches is doing some
servers shifting so I don't know if if
everything will be okay with the
tournament but if this one goes well I
think as of next one we could introduce
some prizes definitely
[Music]
all right that's Queen captures an f2
and something something something let's
say III yeah opening up the light square
bishop and now now what Queen captures
in media yes it is very nice very nicely
done so that's this checkmate let's go
back to the tournament and see how we're
doing okay we have a Quadra a lot of
people Burger King of course I imagine
it would be so since some people who are
maybe 1800 maybe they dropped their
rating to 1700 so they could play and
you know Smurf their way into first
place but you know that's that's okay
so let's let's check out Quadra versus a
rogue Rob Reider nope it's Lou Frank
versus Nick so let's see what Frank
versus Nick a nice a 4 a 5 game and h6
avoiding the Evans gambit or or so they
say when will I show a max you the game
I'm sure at some point I will yeah
it captures is impossible because of
captures whoever said that yeah I'm
currently not playing all that why do
some people think that Lou which is used
an engine I would guess they are jealous
probably might be might have something
to do with that as it was a really great
game
yeah we do have three moderators so I
don't think we'll have a problem with
spam Thank You mr. tall Adler thank you
sir
hey hermano cheers from Norway and these
guys are really going at it like like
it's a bullet game wow what a night the
g3 and now Queen delivers check how will
that night escape okay wow that's I I
cannot guess even one move okay f4 so
Lou Frank very low on time but he
berserk so it's normal we'll see how how
is he able to do it he's down the
exchange gonna be gonna be very tricky
who is the guest well the guest is not
for the stream the guest is for the
podcast and that is still a secret but
like I said you're welcome to try and
guess who will be the guest on the the
first guest on my podcast okay for those
of you who are new berserk King means
that you half your time in half well you
basically lose half of your time but you
win more points for a win you for
example you went two points for a win
and if your berserk you win three points
for a win and here white resigns as
black just delivered checkmate so let's
go back to the tournament and see see
the standing so Nick currently leading
followed by Rob Reider chaukhandi tun
tun and lore Lord touch me and some
other people called kuma guitar Jake
about to and some some names I cannot
pronounce RuPaul South African Air so
let's check out who else is playing all
right
we have okay let's check this one
seems to be seems to be a very
reasonable game yeah no no it's not
though the engine boy but that's always
a good try I've played the guitar some
some 15 years ago and I've now again
took it up but I'm just getting getting
the hang of it since I really haven't
done it in a while no no yell and I will
not be the guest or an almighty but all
good guesses all good guesses they might
be guessed in some future podcast but
not on the first one all right a nice
one by Jack on D so let's bring bring
the tournament back who is now leading
the tournament okay let's check how to
check out let's go let's go to the
second page or maybe even third we said
we were gonna just wing it you know
let's see if Quadra is playing is Cora
playing no it's not no okay guitar Jacob
let's check out this one against
sacrifice god okay let's see if mr.
sacrifice God 1959 who was obviously
born during the candidates tournament of
1959 and of course you all know the
final standings of that tournament is it
some GM guest yes it is Aegean guest it
is definitely a GM guest
some might say even a super GM all right
b5 very nice very nice and now the
Fastpass pawns are marching forward is
gonna be a swift victory for white I
imagine unless sacrifice God is able to
sacrifice something those are all those
are all good tries yes all excellent
tries Magnus visit with rata Hikaru
Kaspar of excellent try
even charge excellent excellent no it's
not Peter Lake oh well although it would
be nice if it was Peter like oh yeah
I'm not going to confirm or deny well
basically I've just denied that it's
Peter Lake oh but other than that I'm
not going to confirm or deny anything
just as yet although I will announce who
it is maybe a week or two weeks before
the podcast so you guys will also be
able to send some of your questions
which are we'll be more than happy to to
ask no it's not about this gate fund I
had I had to deny that one or capablanca
no it's not all for zero
all right so uh a lot of stuff happening
here with that white pawn got all the
way to c7
and why decided to just give up the pawn
for some reason but okay he's up a piece
so it's going to be another Swift to
victory for white yes
again all excellent all excellent
answers which wanna turn on and that is
a good answer no no it's not more fear
or stuntin will the podcast be available
on Google podcast I have no idea I've
never done a podcast before I know I'm
gonna put it on YouTube and I know I've
seen some other places where you could
put podcast so I'm probably gonna put it
on all of those places right I really
have no idea but Google podcast does
seem like like the place I should put
for a podcast yes Fisher clearly yes
that is a good one and it's now three
two one this game this game is very
intense
if black draws this this will be this
will be an epic you know showing but
that point this is finally going it's
gonna be it's gonna be really awesome
how many I'll go how do you join there's
a link in the description below you
click on it and you join that's it that
that's all there is Marcus says I'm not
responding if it's Hikaru
that means it's Hikaru I don't know
could be a good who could be anyone ah
no it's not mr. Barnes but we are soon
soon going to show a lot of mr. Barnes
games mr. Barnes he is a legend okay and
now the technique of delivering a mate
with two queens and guitar Jacob Oh to
shows us how it's done so let's go back
to the tournament see some games maybe
from the middle of the table
let's see mr. Merc
let's see someone with a really cool
name what's a cool name let's see
[Music]
Red Baron that's a cool name maybe
that's his real name but I just lost him
so let's just ignore that okay let's
let's check out the game by team sharp
against Mok sir it's a really wild game
black skin side is completely shattered
but he does have an amazing Center and
it does seem like you just want a piece
so this is a quite the game I imagine
Queen e7 now as you kind of want to keep
that Bishop on c5 and then well then I
definitely prefer black here hey I think
for the contribution yeah it's it's like
it's 6 6 p.m. here so not night but
definitely not morning mr. KH no it's
not not not a hoodie girl ah Peter
Svidler there is a good answer that's
definitely good answer my thoughts on
the TCC well I'm enjoying it very much
even more so than I did the previous
versions of the previous seasons very
very interesting and now allowing ok
going for the bishop instead of
capturing on f6 I don't know capturing
on f6 also had its merits I I imagine
young Gustav shown the egg very good
very good answer very good answer ali
reza now that the that there is quite an
answer yes is it a good answer because
it's correct no or maybe it is Simon
Williams another another good answer and
here what's happening in this game so
black is up a whole rook and there's a
passed pawn on d3
yep I was I was right to call it that I
prefer black I guess unless white grabs
that knight on c6 which for some reason
should happen unless let's say rook c8
defends it but we'll see if team sharp
oh he doesn't find it he goes for this
Queen maneuver sacrificing the night for
what why does he sacrifice for rook c8
he sacrificed yeah I guess it makes
sense you're up so much material rook c8
would would make sense no I'm not
available on Roku 4 for a long time now
and he didn't go for it he had Queen
captures on f6 okay now now white is
definitely back in the game maybe for
for a little bit the joint button is
grayed out for you I Sanchez
it means you haven't played at least 20
games you have to play at least 20
Raider games to be able to enter it is
sort of a countermeasure to or a measure
to prevent cheating as much as possible
now it's woody harrelson another
excellent answer and also now I was ill
even took great great answer yes
Jelena cut I cut my hair yes it's 100
actual yeah it's 100 games for the main
event but it's only 20 20 rate of games
for this little smaller event so here
black is now black is now up the
exchange but it's hard hard to say he's
also very long time I don't know I I
think white will be able to prevail here
but we'll see and that's a look and now
oh my and white in the end one day Sun
time incredible incredible stuff so
let's take it all the way in the let's
say into the to hundreds all right
night King okay sorry I just lost him I
know here he is night King okay he just
started so let's let's dive into that
one you have played 30 Raider games but
the join button is not working probably
because you are over 1700 yeah no it's
it's not so much arena I don't think he
can be considered the super Grandmaster
even though he played spectacularly and
that's a rook width
check and that's a resign okay that was
a that was a fairly quick one so let's
go even even deeper into the rabbit hole
what we have here all right kuma Kershaw
from India let's let's check it out
what's happening here okay so it's some
sort of an end game pretty equal
material unless white has a lot of pawns
other than that you know doing well
we'll see if white is able to take
advantage of this oh that's a nice check
yep nope white will not be able to take
advantage of this the nil dubov that is
that
quite the answer so rook blocks captures
captures and now black is up the
exchange not in a rush to grab that pawn
for some reason now white just defends
it but okay and black gives up a look
yep that's that's the stuff is it
someone from Croatia
okay could be but no no it's not Shaka
dear mama D ro that is there is one good
answer also I'm pretty much every answer
is good as I would really enjoy having
any of those people and on the podcast
but you know I'm still gonna keep it you
know a surprise any corona cases in my
hometown not that I know of not not
officially vladimir artemiev you
probably mean a lotta slower Tamia
but another another great answer AHA did
I plan to take a second look at names of
each tube swung immortal game I'll like
you did with an ins immortal
yeah I'm still deciding on I'm still
deciding on whether to to start redoing
some previous videos that are like
really famous games but I've done a
video and they're a long time ago I'm
still deciding on that but we'll see
there's a lot more to do before I start
making remakes and okay that passed pawn
required White's to grab that so now
black can just wait and hope for a
stalemate
we'll see if white white is able to
deliver checkmate here and how which
technique will white use it's gonna be
gonna be crazy stuff alright and we have
the the ladder technique no we don't and
rook c8 mate
very nice
so going deeper into the rabbit hole
let's see some other guys how they're
doing it red sheep all right I wouldn't
mind a game by the red sheep
Arion from India all right let's check
out this nope that game finished sorry
let's see
easy chess noob nope plain Baker alright
plain Baker is just about to start the
game against the shark bite but failed
shark by shark bite but failed yeah no I
would definitely love to have 11 over
but what happened to him it's just
there's just no words to express that I
mean it's just horrible when when will
there be a saga on an Tigran Petrosian
well at some point I mean I'm not the
one choosing the sagas I will make a
poll and you guys choose the saga that's
how it's been up until this point and I
might overrule that rule at some point
I mean I'm planning to cover the the
avro tournament so we're gonna kind of
switch back into some cup of Blanco game
selection games but between early
between games but we'll see how it goes
thankful for the contribution
contribution alexander lukashenko ban
and also KH thank you what do I
recommend for beginners in chess well
I'm not really the one to recommend
stuff but I definitely recommend you you
study the end the game grab any resource
any book on the endgame and just study
the endgame and you will better
understand all the parts of the game
show more Hastings 1895 games yeah also
a tournaments the cover fully at some
point ok black with the two bishops I
really I really like black but we'll
just have to see how do you how do you
continue Bishop e5 seems nice attacking
the Queen maybe you can get your own
Queen into the attack and he goes for it
ok I would never give up a bishop like
that but ok you still have the light
square one so Oh Queen f6 very nice
giving up the c7 pawn for nope white not
interested probably want to shift that
Bishop over to c6 and then get the rook
rook to e8 now makes sense definitely is
part of the greatest I don't know it
sounds like a job for the people in the
chat to answer part sing thanks for the
contribution and is it Anand you heard
he was stuck in Europe nope it's not
Anand I will I will mention that
although I do hope to get on and at some
point also and yes he stuck in Berlin I
think he cannot get back to India so and
I don't think German is allowing anyone
to enter or leave at the moment do I
know
Vlado kawatche which no I don't know him
personally random thanks for the
contribution Michael chill each or even
issue of each well that's that's
definitely a tough one as I'm not I'm
not an expert in that field but I think
like even if you which is like the the
the genius when it comes to that
I don't stream on Twitch no and I think
you cannot I mean you could stream both
on twitch and YouTube simultaneously but
it's it's like a policy breach so you
would either get banned on on twitch on
or on YouTube or both it's starting
chess at 20 years of age too late to try
and get above 2000 nope that's whenever
you you start that's the perfect perfect
time to start okay well what's happening
here
okay now why to definitely improve this
position what is planning Bishop to d4
now going for g7 to deliver all now now
bishop area makes sense that's a tough
one that's a shame for for why for black
who had an excellent game with the two
bishops but okay congratulations to mr.
mister shark but but shark bite but
failed on that wonderful game and we are
20 we're over half half the tournament
is over and let's see how are we doing
at the top okay a lot of people Burger
King as I as I imagined so let's see a
game by the leader PMF a childhood
memories vs. p.m. RF one two three four
five
all right both of them Burger King so so
I guess it's almost a bullet game a
minute and a half both Bishop f8
interesting keeping keeping an eye on d8
okay now character scatters King goes to
c7
I imagine yeah it's gonna be gonna be
wild I don't know if I will be having
like a celebratory 600k tournament III
wasn't I wasn't thinking about you know
commemorating the 600,000 subscribers
milestone I was gonna wait for it at
least like maybe 750 but we could do one
I guess maybe even next Friday since
that we're gonna continue the algorithm
a turf ride
tournament so maybe we could also make
it into a tournament and here white
would just win the piece and why no
white doesn't want it white wants to
finish the game
oh if rook captures rook delivers mate
very nice very tricky Wow how will white
deal with this well obviously you trade
rooks and play f3 or that and now mate
ha that was that was excellent that was
just great good one mr. p.m. RF 1 2 3 4
5 ok let's go let's go all the way to
the back see what's happening here
probably some wild games here okay let's
at least those who have one point so I
know they're actually playing ah we are
going to do the Delian saga as well at
some point shady soldier
okay let's maybe maybe one that's okay
this one seems to be going on pretty
crazy
shady soldier let's let's check that out
extreme D versus shady soldier so a nice
end game where black is up a pawn and
it's a very nice pass D pawn with
bishops of opposite color so this will
be a very nice thing to check okay
that's a free pawn now you're gonna
defend it and now it's four points each
thank you mr. Potter Patrick's wata and
sorry about that Joshua Joshua Yaak
which wants me to say something in in
Croatian what would you like me to say
yes just was chest was somewhat
different during the capablanca saga wow
I look away for a second and black is
down a piece this is this is crazy
will shady soldier be able to withstand
this pressure and pushes a pond to
victory that is the question I think so
Queen and now it's okay
and now mate in one Queen a one win each
one no not interested he's gonna go the
other way around
okay it's gonna be wild for 14 more
seconds okay now those pawns are
dangerous and Bishop II won okay that
will do very nice mr. shady soldier good
game let's see let's see what happens
next deadly Knights mr. deadly night
okay we lost that one Red Baron okay why
is it updating so fast
that's just all right mr. Red Baron
versus our own one two three Kumar
yeah matter is just the you know
sleeping on the floor so not really not
really doing all that much yeah I can't
for I can't at the moment but when I
improve my my guitar skills
I will definitely you know play
something for you guys another problem
and I'm not going to tell the English
joke that's that's for sure how am i
enjoying the Final Fantasy 7 remake well
I only played that the absolute first
part where you where you have to blow up
the macro reactor and well so far I'm
just loving it like everything
everything is just awesome
ever thought they would ruin the remake
like they ruin everything but or or
maybe they have are just having to reach
that part but so far so far is great
evergreen game the evergreen game is was
not played by nimzowitsch so it's not a
part of the sorcery series thank you
mister Remco renko heart of eight for a
contribution yeah you can live of chess
if you're really good at chess I imagine
aha I wouldn't know
Basra even Pablo which there be a
positive captures captures yes Final
Fantasy seven is a game and I'm the good
one at that
some would say the best and by some I
mean me okay rugby it goes after the
Queen Queen goes after the a7 pawn so
seems like it seems like a wild game
Bishop c4 King obviously g1 how will
white do this probably trade off nah
you're down the exchange not not too
much you can do grab the pawn and play
try and flag your opponent some some
will do that
Talia B&I groobly she hissed it cut
hello
thank mr. Kumar gee thank you you are
also amazing
yeah that shows my age that being better
than Fanfan z10 it really does can you
be a mod you are tall sure thing man
there we go you're now you're now a mod
there we go
we need more mods like we need as many
mods as possible
oh that's a mystery caress Farah that's
a that's a that's a tough joked
especially that to mention on stream who
likes Queen everyone likes Queen who
wouldn't love Queen all right Aaron one
two three kumar is a very long time so
in he didn't even berserk he just didn't
know how to how to push for his
advantage
so i think white will just play 3 H 3
and flag in a thank you mister a Gromit
Mickey grammatical I imagine one of the
olders all the subscribers to the
channel thanks thanks man
also Thank You mr. panther sgb thank you
guys and Arun Kumar is flag well not
flagged he just lost in time he spent
way too much time on that so let's go
deeper into the rabbit hole maybe to the
400 and then when we have the last 15
minutes of the tournament we're gonna
focus on the leaders to see who will
take home the bacon
I believe that's the expression although
I'm very interested the of the origin of
this saying where do you find bacon to
take home
monk easy alright let's check out monk
easy mark horseman yes you can be a mod
sure thing man
sure thing if I can find you in the chat
yep there we go your mod only don't
abuse your mod powers you know with with
mod powers comes great responsibility
I've been to Hungary once but I was like
5 so I don't really count that as being
in Hungary do I think short played
Robert James Fisher
I'm sure Fisher played online at some
point
I mean who why wouldn't he I mean
there's just no reason to think that he
never played a game online but did he
actually play those games against the
Nigel short I don't know I don't think
so
could be but I really I doubt it
there you go man you are now a mod and I
don't I don't think we need more than 5
balls for the moment at least so what we
have here
c4 Bishop captures black really have a
struggling to develop white grabbed a
lot of space there but maybe that's his
plan we'll see
GM hink ro is the best I don't know who
is GM King karo mod is a moderator
people who you know make sure that
everything is you know finding Channel
and insulting anyone and so on yeah and
don't spam that you want to be a mod
spamming I want to be a mod is also just
spamming all right let us focus on the
game a bit favorite song I don't know
I'm pretty sure I have one I just have
no idea what it is at the moment and
thanks mister Thank You mr. sanchita
shablak for for the contribution
favorite song hoo-hoo-hoo know who could
know their favorite song I mean it's not
not an easy question smoke a cigar
yeah I've stopped smoking like two years
ago maybe I don't know how long has it
been already I think it's yeah I think
this month it will be two years well no
the Evergreen game is not a part of the
sorcery series because I imagine the
sorcery series be without any famous
players so although there is one one
tall game in the sorcery series there is
a good reason why I put it there which I
explained in the sorcery series but
other than that do more to get paid yes
in in praise and you know in bragging
rights that that's how mods are paid
favorite series well without the final
season I would have always said the game
of Thrones but now now you know anything
just goes have I seen your my Wikipedia
page yes I've seen it I have no idea who
made it but but I have seen it all right
what do we have here white a very low on
time
and black threatening mate so we'll see
if white figures it out and how how he
will defend it alright not not bad
probably get the other night or the rook
into the attack somehow I didn't imagine
you'd do it like that but okay there is
a discovery on the Queen now so you have
to react to that and now what you trade
and bring the other Knight to d5 or yup
I imagined he would go for that from
which country do I have the most viewers
it's I think it's still last time I
checked it was the United States some
thirty thirty one percent and then India
eleven percent followed by I think
Philippines maybe eight percent and then
it's like Canada Germany Norway at six
percent and then everything else is
below 6% did I intentionally lose
against the comedians no I may I may
have played a bit careless in the
opening but I did not expect them to
play such such moves after after I i
blundered that corn in the opening it
was just downhill from there there was
nothing I could do who do I support in
Magnus cross and Invitational well um I
don't support anyone I'm I'm very happy
to see everyone win but obviously
everyone wants to see Ali Reza now take
some scalps there okay so a good win by
monkeys ek now let's go back we have 12
more minutes in the tournament so let's
check out and the leaders childhood
memories and p.m. RF one two three four
five still leading but we already saw
some games by them so let's check out
mr. real silver shades against Carl
Marcus
what's the viewership from Croatia I
think it's less than one percent like
0.7% and what do I think about Karpov
coming to the akka I imagine you you're
talking about the Academy he's about to
start I think you know I definitely
welcome it I don't know what's what's
he's gonna what the concept we're gonna
be like or anything like that but I mean
it can only be it can only be good yes I
accept challenges but not at the moment
as we are currently showcasing some some
games from from subscribers and white
will definitely get flagged here or not
wow that that's some supreme pre moving
action but still he gets flagged if he
was if he were able to avoid flagging
here that would be some exemplary you
know
mouse mouse moves all right mr. Kavon we
haven't seen a game by mr. Kavon from
canada can I explain the meaning of
agamotto
no I can't I might be able to do it at
some point but not just now
couple Blanc or morphe well
again hard to say hey thanks for the
contribution Mr Davenport where it's
yeah yeah it's been a real real shocker
but you know well what can you do you
know it's just like life slapping you in
the face but yeah thanks for the
contribution also one of the one of the
earliest subscribers to the channel what
is my job in real life well believe it
or not it's actually this I did have a
job but I I quit my job some two years
ago as a graphic designer
so now I just promote chess people enjoy
it so I thought well why not do that
instead so c5 very nice makes sense
so they also this is one of the games
that will decide the winner of this
tournament as childhood memories is
currently leading the tournament and
he's again burger king so we'll see how
he will how he will do those are some
very nice points
a double chop I live in three shifts in
Croatia it's impossible to pronounce if
you're not from around here but we do
have some excellent beer of course now
and no one can visit at the moment due
to the current situation but you know
when it all comes down you are you're
welcome to come visit
thanks mr. Edward Lee from California
USA yes I will be very safe that that's
how I roll
all right so now it's equal time so
childhood memories definitely successful
in in hyper hyper in this berserk in
this but we'll see how it goes thanks
mr. jolly suit yes I have seen the movie
upon sacrifice about Bobby Fisher
bye-bye Tobey Maguire but I didn't
really enjoy it as it was right about
the time where I was reading a lot about
Fisher and I've read several books about
him some nice biographies and I just
didn't feel that the movie did him
justice but it was i watch it at the
moment that it came out so might I might
enjoy it a bit more now I don't know III
might have to re-watch it but what do we
have here that's a nice check and
whatever happens I'm pretty sure Black
Bull yeah lose so childhood memories
another victory which means he is still
tied for first place with with mr.
Palmer one two three four five
cobra-cabra hadras says that tomorrow
add yourself to your favorite team in
the cobra hydras team battle and leeches
see the link at our matters forum yes
you are welcome to join in in the action
bye bye hard record the boat yeah people
some people are spamming but it's you
know it's a good luck that we have so
many mods alright let's see here a nice
game
al-bakr versus not Navin Kumar Itachi
sorry mister wasted the pro I didn't see
it the chat is really really fast so I
tried to keep an eye on the chat as well
as the game you know it's it's not an
easy thing my favorite beer well I I
kind of get that question a lot I have
no idea why but I do have to say it's
the creature watch copy whoa here made
made in my hometown do I think berserk
King is good in tournaments well if you
play against an opponent do you think is
not not really on your level and you
want to beat him quickly gain more
points then I guess yeah Burger King is
is the way to go thanks mr. sock piano
for the for the kind words when did I
start the channel where I actually
started at the channel in 2007 I just
didn't use it for chess I used it for as
I worked at as a well I shot weddings
edited weddings with my father so we
used it for for weddings mostly and then
at some point when I decided to do some
chess videos I just made those videos
invisible since we didn't need them
anymore and I continued using the
channel so that's why it says that I
created it at 2 in 2007 but I've only
used it for chess since late 2016
I think or late 2015 I think late 2016
yeah uh Soviet dog yeah I could lower
the games needed to participate in the
tournament but that would make it too
easy for cheaters to apply because this
way
even if cheater supply they first have
to play the games and then it maybe you
know makes it a lot less enjoyable for
them so I don't know it's it's kind of a
my idea but we'll see if it if it works
do you speak Russian no I don't but it's
you know on my agenda to learn Russian
my content makes your Corona filled they
better I'm very happy to hear that so he
didn't go for h3 he allowed the capture
here we're now going to see why well
you're a bit late to join in the action
on the 1701 but the next one starts in
like nine minutes so you will be able to
join that one so how do you finish this
or can white finish this oh nice Bishop
captures rook captures with Czech Queen
captures and Queen b7 mate I like it and
if you don't react just Bishop captures
on d6 it works just the same so I don't
know if black can defend this
I guess maybe Bishop c8 no that's even
worse yeah
Queen b5 check bishop blocks and then
bishop characters on d6 yeah it's the
same white still prevails
yeah just Bishop d7 and captures on b6
and that's that's the stuff how often do
I do live streaming not very often where
did the name Ivan Madar come from asks
Erik vulture that is that is a secret
that I might reveal at some point but
not at this particular one and he is
unable to find the defense so he I guess
waits for the time to run out because
there is no defense yeah he just resigns
here so good stuff and we have three
more minutes childhood memories in the
lead so let's enjoy a game by our leader
against the ottoman Belgard other people
watching me in Croatia there are there a
few but there are he's are another
supposed to be English no we'll fuchsia
become world champion huh it all depends
on him in blitz and rapid definitely and
we'll see about classical in classical
he first has to qualify for a candidate
win the candidates and then then it's
just it's not easy
what openings do I think are overrated I
don't think there are overrated openings
especially in this day and age I mean
yeah you can play anything and still
have a good game does the nickname a
good not or have anything to do with the
previous wedding job no it doesn't know
it doesn't thanks thanks for the
contribution mr. michael snow I I think
Volusia is just a beast like he he gave
an interview for just 24 where he said
they asked him how how often does he
study chess and he said like maybe not
the entire day but I think about it the
entire day and I study studied a lot and
of course when he's coming after Magnus
to when Magnus says everything else he
has the play Magnus now he's on chess 24
he has well he has a girlfriend he has a
you know million other things and I
don't know that might reflect a little
bit on chess and when you're up against
a monster like Fallujah who's just you
know everything he does his chest it's
just incredibly hard
no mr. Aaron Robinson I don't think you
could beat Magnus now but you could
probably be these beat his app you know
maybe like at age five to nine I think
you could give that a go and we have 45
more seconds childhood memories posts as
he's now the winner so we're just gonna
wait out these 35 seconds to see who
wins the tournament and and and how it
went - definitely probably gonna have
some changes here at the top
Anand Anand Anand is an absolute legend
I'm still reading his book the the mind
master and I even I like him even more
now that I'm reading the book as you
really you really see what kind of guy
he is which we know from interviews and
from all this official business he does
you don't really get a get an insight
into the person of Anand but if you read
his book it's incredibly enjoyable all
right so the tournament is officially
over Ivan Madar Friday sub 1700 arena
which in the future will be called
meadow arena if you guys are ready to
find it and I will publish the winners
on my social media and Twitter Facebook
and whatnot
so make sure you congratulate the
winners so first place childhood
memories of course we don't know who
anyone is but congratulations South
African Air second place in third place
a Carl Marcus who I think has like a 93
percent win rate really really
incredible but no berserk so it's hard
to get all the way up to the top four
place real silver shades then it's a
p.m. RF one two three four five who is
leading the tournament for quite a long
time if I remember then Naveen Kumar
Kumar Kumar itachi in sixteen seven we
have at Aegis law
then in eighth we have a charismatic
enigma in nine I just suck well
obviously not since you've got nine
place in a tournament of 2,000 people
nine
95 people and Cavan 856 in tenth place
and we can also check out some other
then coronavirus Johanna Casanova the
Safa aero XL capoeira a lord touch me
box fighter at doom castle 18 third jeho
T Roy Othman Belgard and he de
unsink in twentieth so congratulations
to everyone who who showed up who who
made this tournament is over so vast so
thank you all and especially thank
congratulations to the winners like I
said we're gonna publish all the results
so make sure to congratulate everyone
can I please say captures captures
captures there you go the next
tournament is starting in 9 minutes and
here we have 1500 players and here since
there is no limited rating we even have
some well titled players like fede
master gorky pauline here and the
national master young needs and I
imagine some others bruno party which is
here who is also who is also a very
strong player but i guess he didn't get
his title verified then we have a women
feed a master from croatia unbreakable
one so glad to see we have a lot of
strong women players as well and here we
have candidate master squishy so
obviously this tournament will be a bit
stronger and ok since it starts at 8
minutes i I guess I could accept a
challenge while we wait a nice 3-minute
game there we have it a nice 3-minute
game against the gym so let me just open
this in a different tab so
panniers poacher
yeah like I said we could play one game
while we wait
Thank You mr. SLM solutions from Hong
Kong Wow Andromeda says that I be the mm
elope layer in a classical game in using
the Evans gambit Wow that is that is
very impressive I would not mind seeing
that if it's really a classical game so
I don't think mr. the Jim is here so
we're gonna the link to the new
tournament is also in the description
below it's actually the first link you
will see the second link oh the gym is
here
he goes for the Timothy three so I guess
we grab the center okay
we could capture here go d5 maybe yeah
make sense go there should be four and
even trade
nice nice calm okay
I'm even gonna capture with the Queen
here huh
positive Carlo bubi she's posed love
yeah let's go see five here
Thank You mr. mr. James snap
ok-hee castled he religious go knight c6
Thank You mr. Adrian holy heck all right
so he's doing very well here he does
have these two pawns but other than that
nothing to worry about I'm very happy
with my position I have some reasonable
development I'm gonna get the rooks into
the game and hopefully be able to do
something let's go let's go rook here
this pawn could be could become a target
sometimes in the future like maybe maybe
even now okay not maybe now but let's go
here okay still not trading maybe night
here go for some of this now we'll see
yeah okay look here I'm gonna recapture
with the night so I get some attacks
here and see three this is always useful
here I can always shift it to g6 Thank
You mr. robbed are what are my five top
favorite players I don't have a top five
I do have I do have a top one but I'm
sure I'm sure that's no secret since
he's like in every one of my videos the
link for the next tournament is in the
description first thing you will see it
says join the main event here
okay that's check I said I'm gonna
recapture with the night here if rook
here can I capture no I can't so I'm
gonna have to bring the knight back into
the game but I am doing very well in
time so he's going to defend it okay
let's get the knight back into the game
and that's a free pawn I guess but yeah
okay let's trade everything here
captures captures captures and I guess
captures here so that's a that's a nice
clean pawn if he could he can capture
here definitely but his rook is hanging
so he asked the first to deal with that
okay he's going for this do I mind this
yeah I mind this of course I mind this
[Music]
yeah we're gonna have to do it like this
and capture with the Jeep on so I don't
get made it would be would be a shame if
that happened if he captures of course
yeah I have to capture with the Jeep on
oh no I missed check and he picks up the
rook okay he missed that so I'm very
happy he missed that wow that was close
he actually he could have won the game
here he could have won the game here
good thing is very long time
okay we're good now let's just push the
pawn make him worry about stuff okay
let's grab that rook check we win the
rook we go for this
I guess not much for the Queen to do
thanks mr. bony Samuel thank you and
let's not blunder the game or anything
so let's just push this pawn okay he
wants this pawn I'm not sure I want to
give it to him so let's go rook here
check he doesn't have anything I can
just hide should work nicely yeah I can
just hide so this is no longer an issue
and now we go back Queen here or we even
push the pawn yeah we push the pawn yeah
block okay was a good game you had that
Queen g4 check if he found it would be
would be game but you were very long
time so good game man
definitely good game do I know Young's
public no I do not know Young's public
Carol oh yes Lucas : I remember your
name from the from the sum of the first
streams ever
okay the tournament starts in one minute
so we managed to squeeze in that won one
game Ian and LEM just grab some more
water and I'll be back in like 30
seconds so prepare for some Sun great
chest action
all right we're back all right
a lot of people interested in this
tournament I guess almost yeah three
3600 people came to support us so thanks
for that
where is meadow the mail is actually
behind me I don't know if you can see
him I'm pretty sure you should sometimes
he just pops in the back thank you mr.
mr. Dillon johani yeah there you go
there's meadow all right all right this
is gonna be this is gonna be way more
intense but or maybe not you know
low-rate the games are also super
intense so let's check out games by our
top seeds a th four per one with a
rating of 2600 very very impressive and
also our economy with 25:13 thank you
mr. punished even for the contribution
so what do we have here okay so they're
just gonna RAM at it really fast since
they are there are good players and then
we're gonna focus on the position a
little bit later yeah cap remove the
Queen and now at some point you develop
the bishop very good to a3 you prepare
d5 so black cannot castle or you can
maybe you can Castle queenside but you
kind of don't want to do that
all right huh yeah makes sense now with
the bishop slicing all the way here
makes it hard for black castle black has
his work cut out for him definitely
oh he allows that very nice Oh
Bishop h5 nice then that that's the
Queen so a very quick game very nicely
done by mr. ATH four for one
so let's check out some other games
there is marshal marshal D who's been
berserk in the first game so let's check
that out against mr. speed chess 1904 am
i simp I don't know what that is sir
[Music]
why'd I lose against summers well he he
played incredible chess it's very simple
do I need a mod well double chop since
you're asking yes you can be a mod there
we go you are now a sext mod Wow I don't
think anyone has so many mods this is
this is great
no I didn't see their game against the
visit but I imagine with it crush them
with ease
do I know who is the the woman freedom
master from Croatia no I don't but I'm
sure if if it says in the profile you
can click on on her profile and check it
out
yes I can say it but I don't want to say
it ah there we go Martin Eric says that
it's not a no image beer on it there you
go alright let's see what's happening
here Marshall D it's a good name for
chess player Marshall I've heard of a
marshal in the chess world that's that's
a wild beep on
oh yeah could be could be Frank James
Marshall yeah
yep Capablanca used to play Marshall and
not only that you know if it wasn't for
Marshall capablanca would never have
gotten into that tournament in 1913 and
well it was his first big international
tournament and if it wasn't for Marshall
he he wouldn't even be able to play it
so good guy that Marshall
yes Shiva my I am a candidate master but
but only in Croatia
since my elo is lower than than what is
required to be it to be a candidate
master okay nicely doubling on the D
file so what what do we have here
captors captures white is up upon should
be good for white 95
and white is doing better on time so I
do imagine white will be able to win
this
yes very epic thank you mister punished
even when is my birthday its 16th of
June so maybe maybe we don't even have
to celebrate it in lockdown by then or
maybe we do we'll see how long this this
whole thing lasts Shanna's are says I
always want to play chess after watching
your videos you're a huge inspiration
that's that's what I want to hear what
some videos and then go go destroy some
people online tournament link the link
that the tournament is the first thing
you see in the description below it says
join the main event here then you click
on it and that's going to the tournament
all right we have Bishop captures King
captures and now an ice king and rook
endgame with with now the exact same
amount of pawns so we'll see if black
will be able to to do something here as
he is very low on the clock
[Music]
and how are you guys enjoying the tea
CEC if you are enjoying that I don't
know sometimes I upload a little
stalkerish for example and you guys are
like some of you are like oh yeah those
games are the best and then some of you
guys are we don't want engine games no
give us good more fish saga but I you
know I obviously can't that's why I do
both but it's impossible to do both at
the same time I do not have a favorite
spider
that's a weird sentence but someone
asked me that yeah how often do I play
League of Legends I played like one week
in the year and then I realized well
then I remember why I stopped playing it
okay that was a free rook but flagging
is always better than a free rook all
right so we're gonna dive a little bit
further in okay here we have a let's see
some games by some of our titled friends
all right
let's go a bit deeper okay here we see
the master Madhavi oops all Filipino is
here let's check out his game let's see
how Filipino is doing he's up against
Simon 38 alright going for four the
usual stuff being attacked on the Kings
side is gonna be is gonna be pretty wild
I don't know what rise of kingdoms is
nope so obviously I don't play it how
did I lose to those Indian comedians
well again they played a remarkable game
and I was just I was just completely
defenseless what's my favorite gambit of
course I will I will allow the chat to
tell you what is my favorite gambit no I
don't think you've seen dr. Nick Turse
Stein I don't think I think he has
better things to do then then play three
plus zero tournaments on some some some
weird events yes that is true the chat
has spoken wisely it is the Evans gambit
yes yes I usually don't appreciate it
when the chat goes fast but when it goes
really fast saying the Evans gambit it's
really looking it's really looking
awesome
okay so black really doing the number on
white or is he we're gonna see now
raakhi eight i imagine in front of the
king and then all sorts of nasty
discoveries are possible so which one
will he use you have played the
Halloween gambit I actually use it quite
often in bulletins blitz but you know
most people don't don't even keep the
material they just give it right back
yeah I don't think I'll be doing any
fortnight videos that is I I don't
really appreciate the game and Queen G
to mate let's see it Queen G to Derry
there it is so good game by Filipino
let's see let's see what else what else
can we find
okay there we have cm squishy and we've
lost them ha nope here it is let's see
mr. squishy how he does I don't know who
squishy is but
we're gonna check out one of the games
we've already finished the sub 1700
tournament but yeah we will definitely
be showcasing some other games from some
of our lower rated friends yes Pedro I
am playing the new Final Fantasy well
rather I only tried it and then I you
know had some stuff to do and I made a
video and then now I'm streaming but I'm
pretty sure I'm gonna play it a bit more
tomorrow what's my favorite vitamin well
vitamin B of course and D I would have
to go with B and D yell and ice laughing
she she's probably thinking wow this is
some weird dude saying stuff like that
do I enjoy hiking I do I do but I rarely
hike all right what do we have here two
nights in the rook against the bishop
and two rooks but you know Knights are
very tricky so once that Bishop moves in
I'd see five will attack a six and be
seven or not Bishop prevents it which
makes sense and well black should be
better but will black be better we're
just gonna have to wait and see dim
voyage versus candidate master squishy
all right look after rook captures very
nice Knight f5 and my favorite fabric I
don't know man
cashmere I have no idea
ah please give me a modeling who
requested a modeling here okay Madan you
are removed from being a moderator so
I'm accepting one more moderator since
Maddon has to go if anyone is interested
in modding where where to now this rook
still stuck anyone guarding that 8u pawn
not not where you want to be h5 probably
coming at some point kicking the night
back and now it's becoming harder and
harder for white to defend Bishop c5
will attack that night probably to clear
g2 and it's gonna be hard my laugh is
very similar to Jose Mourinho i-i've
never heard Jose Mourinho laugh but some
other people suggested that as well so
so I will take a word for it do I like
cats
no I love cats cats are awesome I'm not
like a cat person or a dog person I like
both cats and dogs
do I like soccer no not so much
even though a lot of people don't like
it when when you say soccer you know
that people prefer football so I've
heard someone told me that when I when I
said soccer on the channel alright and
the white somehow managed to survive
this and now is doing well down a pawn
but check check and I think we're gonna
have a flag off here a good classical
flag off what do I think in the
difference of the soundtrack of the new
and old Final Fantasy 7 I've only just
started the new one but I would have
heard so far I did enjoy I don't imagine
I don't know I don't think noble
lamotte's who I believe is the original
one who who created the themes for the
first game I don't I don't know if he
was also present for for the remake I
somehow doubt it but I know probably it
can't be as good as the original but you
know it's been it's been ok so far okay
Marley we feed a master we said we were
gonna check out one of the games so ok
though they're already down to down to
the ending and white is up a piece with
with a passed pawn and b7 so should be
fairly straightforward if anyone still
doesn't know how to join the tournament
first link in the description below
takes you to the tournament page and you
just enjoy christian min Cove
I have not hosted anyone via
couchsurfing for quite some time now
since I don't have anywhere to put them
at the moment but I might I might in the
future
huh-ah
FM FM RV from slovenia it's actually a
new account since there's a question
mark next to his rating so not not
Alicia's men I see my favorite start
what is that my favorite start currently
I don't watch any anime and it's a draw
why did I miss was it a three fold or
something why is it a draw
okay that's weird but what I wanted to
mention is that I did I did check out
Castlevania
season 3 which was which was ok I really
enjoyed season 1 and 2
gorky Pelin in in the back a bit lost
his first games Burger King a lot so
let's see okay you guys wanted a game
bye-bye
women feeding master unbreakable so
let's see how she is doing
Burger King against Ali RSD so we'll see
how that goes
well doing very well that night doing a
good job so it's a win and let's let's
see what's happening okay let's see
another one since we only we only saw a
fraction of that one uh-huh and she's
playing against scott tenorman's dad i
played against scott tenorman's that
twice during streams so he's a he's
fairly irregular I don't know if Scott
tenorman plays but scott tenorman's dad
obvious obviously does know I don't play
the piano I'm I'm very sorry I don't I
wish I played the piano but I don't my
favorite tea well probably means tea but
also Earl Grey just because jean-luc
Picard drinks that one all right what do
we have here
so no Burger King here just nice nice
chess Scott tenorman is a South Park
character seriously I've watched like 20
seasons of South Park white why doesn't
Scott tenorman ring a bell that's that's
really weird huh
so a queen trade very nice and we'll see
what happens it's a very nice CC for
pawn that night is coming to d3 at some
point probably not while the bishop is
still there yeah push them all the way
and now you have the trade of the dark
square the shop oh okay all your double
rooks on the C file and then you push it
okay we'll see what now
ah Bishop h6 nicely done huh
okay this is becoming trickier and
trickier a fantastic hike into the wild
nature here in Norway yeah I'm sure
that's something I would enjoy hmm he's
Cartman's dad really know is the guy
whose parents Cartman cooked into chili
and fed it to him
okay I'm gonna have to brush up on my
South Park and knowledge as obviously
it's not so vast and there goes our our
friend the sea poem so two knights
against two bishops white is up upon
Scotland okay no longer but yeah as you
can see scott tenorman's dad really
really a tricky guy I seem to have
beaten him two times but I remember
those were some really really really
wild games so let's see his bishops are
doing good work now and that passed pawn
will soon start marching forward I think
that point should have started marching
forward a long time ago but favorite
combat game that's a good question
favorite combat game ha I don't know I
think Magnus Carlsen versus Gawain Jones
in Isle of Man last year wasn't last
year and was the Isle of Man I don't
know when Magnus blunders a piece in the
opening and then he just comes back but
you know after you know
Gawain made some suboptimal moves and
then it was almost like Carlsen
sacrificed it for like some crazy
positional initiative I don't know
can nipple win the candidates a and we
have a what I draw I draw by
insufficient material the best kind of
draw there you have it so that was
really wild
good game mr. scott tenorman's dad the
underdog who prevailed let's check out
okay no games here Oh cm squishy all
right we have from Germany from Germany
Cairo Cairo sus yes nepo could
definitely win where's the wig and the
cigarette oh that's for death for a
different stream I don't just bring
those out for for like any stream
Cartman's ginger brother
I think you guys are just messing with
me now is Fallujah the next champion ah
it's impossible to predict you know
things like that
my favorite mountain will probably
probably mountain from Game of Thrones
yeah I will definitely check that out to
see who actually is scott tenorman's dad
that's it's actually quite weird I mean
I've watched like really like 20 seasons
of South Park it's really weird that I
don't know that huh yawn is currently at
home yeah he would of course join me but
it's you know due to the coronavirus and
everything you can't just invite people
to your house
thanks mr. Schock Brawl you are also the
best the meter says we can hear Jelena
that's good that's because she is also
playing in the tournament though the
Indian boy is still at home as you know
he did have a baby so spends a lot more
time at home now at the moment when is
the podcast well I will mention that the
podcast will be somewhere between ha
between 12th of May and 20th of May
definitely somewhere in that week
can anin be part of the next candidates
tournament of course he can he's still
an active player if you're an active
player anyone can be a part of the
candidates tournament
ah thanks lawmaker now I remember who
scott tenorman's that is okay I've seen
that episode yeah I was a was the wild
one
alright what do we have here
capture the bishop or even better go
after the bishop that way huh
yep something had to go something had to
go and okay no one berserks here I
thought I thought there was some reserve
thing going on but obviously not so via
dog yes we will have a tournament next
week also we're gonna have two events
one the small one which will be called
meadow arena and then the big one and
we're probably gonna have some prizes as
well I decided not to do any prizes for
this one since like I said I didn't know
if we just servers were stable enough as
they were switching servers did this
game miss mate but probably but you know
he's upper Queen and the rook so I don't
think he's all that worried about mate
although he should do something
otherwise I don't think this is how
flagging works and yes he flagged him
Wow good job again the underdog prevails
this is turning into the event of the
underdogs okay let's check some other
since this tournament is two hours
unlike the previous one that was one
hour so we can spend a bit more time
watching some lower rated players and
see how they they deal with it okay
our friend here decided to take to take
a break tall in danger okay we missed
that one okay let's see this one from
Sri Lanka
damia from Sri Lanka against the
Rumplestiltskin 21 can we see a yelling
us game I don't know
I have to ask her Jelena can we show one
of your games okay she says okay we're
gonna show Sherwin a game of Jelena
after we finish with this one but it's
gonna be over quickly since there's 12
seconds left there was an end game book
I always recommend it I'm pretty sure
you're talking about
Margaret's Keys end game manual probably
probably that one huh all right let's go
back to the tournament let's see oh no
all right let's see what happens she's
playing against Almighty pong God and
there's a lot of action going on here
huh she's down a piece but anything can
happen it's a 3-minute game so let's see
the night on g5 hands I'm not actually
gonna comment so because she can hear me
I'm just gonna nod hmmm post-rock edgar
every day that meet miss was glorious
yeah flagging is losing on time what's
my favorite Mexican salsa I don't I
don't have a favorite Mexican salsa or
or salsa for that matter how's the
pauran teen life well you know it's a
quarantine life can't really choose okay
those phones are really marching forward
and yelling and doing much better on
time
so it's gonna be you know it's gonna be
wild
can I explain the difference between
bullet and other formats well a bullet
is obviously 1 plus oh and and no bullet
is well believe you can play blitz 3
plus oh boy it's 5 plus so you can play
wrap it you know 10 plus so 15 plus oh
and I think before okay the shop g5
check very nice this is a this is a
crazy game
no I'm not going to join the commentary
on the Magnus Invitational tomorrow but
I will of course throw some of the games
after after they are finished I think he
plays Hikaru in the first round okay so
not going for the rook interesting
evenly which it says I was below 1700 at
the time at what time at what time were
you below 1700 okay the knight joins the
action wow this is this is wild have
ever tried Indian cuisine yeah but
probably not not original I mean
something you mix up here I don't think
it can resemble the real deal okay
Knight e4 check and then Knight captures
on c7 check wow this is this is crazy
stuff and those pawns are scary can I
make the Morphy saga daily I could but I
also have to do some other things you
know I can't just do the morphe saga
would be would be pretty pretty intense
if I only did that
okay this is crazy black is up a rook
and the beast but white has all these
central pawns Wow
start the Carlson saga no I think it's
too early and Magnus is too young for us
to be doing the Carlson saga we're gonna
do it at some point and we will we did
do we did do the world chess champion
the candidates tournament of 2013 and
the world chess championship match
against on and so that's a sort of a
like a little saga
okay what's what's happening here so
crazy crazy stuff
seventeen seconds that's a check Oh
black very long time this is insane
yes I did I did enjoy the game with so
much I know very much that is that is
true wow that's a queen okay now black
will have to do incredibly well not to
lose this on time and now it's just
impossible now it's just three seconds
Jelena is persistent not to use the rook
for the entire game okay now it's in the
game for for the killing blow
and now the flagging begins good game
Jelena
excellent excellent use of of initiative
alright let's check out some other games
let's see mr. Yoshi
mr. Yoshi okay let's check out the game
by me okay mouse yeah that was a there
was a funny game
okay and what's happening here Wow whoa
I guess wow what a free queen okay
I think mr. Yoshi
went a little too much Yolo there yes I
do like I do like Dragon Ball Z yes even
more than then a person should and yes I
I have played dota but I didn't enjoy it
very much here I faced the L&I in a
tournament only once I think it was a
few years ago in a blitz tournament was
dramatic she saw any A+ yeah it's it's
very likely that you that this is the
first livestream by me you've caught
since I don't really let stream that
often but I'm gonna stream every Friday
now to have this like I got mattress
Friday tournaments going on I don't know
thought it'd make a nice nice tradition
at some point alright two seconds and
getting mated with two seconds on the
clock so that's that's always nice
alright
meadow is again having his demons let's
go deeper into the rabbit hole see
what's what's happening here there's mr.
professional okay we have ions in oh
let's see some game okay this looks like
a wild one all pieces all over the board
house quarantine in Croatia well much
better than than in some places I
imagine
you want me to tell you made of story
matter made of stories is a vast one so
at some point it's definitely gonna be
gonna be said or maybe even written it's
quite the story favorite Croatian food I
don't know man probably probably Sarma
know I haven't played Hendon brain not
really not really a fan I'm more of a
fan of just playing
normal chess will I cover a few of these
games I don't know maybe maybe we could
yeah but it's hard to do I mean too many
games are played how would I pick one to
cover like maybe if we just stumbled
upon a very great oh that was nice that
was nice the best was pain so now it was
the Queen and now pretty much anything
wins except that that was weird but
still you can play it now okay now you
just pick up the bishop and and all is
well good game mr mr rawat
huh you advised me to learn Marcel daddy
music in order to improve your finger
style playing okay I will I will check
it out
I will check I have no idea what that is
but I'm Prince screening it and I will
check it out
how good cook is Jelena Jelena is Jelena
is a magnificent cook your understanding
gets better with my analysis I I doubted
but I'm very happy to hear that
why don't I stream on Twitch I don't
know like it's too too laggy maybe it's
just I really you know I don't have that
great of a computer and whenever I see
that something is like laggy for no
reason then I just don't don't like it
like Steam I don't know who why steam
lag that makes no sense but I prefer
YouTube since it's pretty much I mean
it's important for people to be able to
find you and YouTube does the job very
well and I don't know everyone else is
on twitch so I thought maybe I'm just
gonna stay on YouTube seems it seems
like a good idea
PC specs oh there and they're like
prehistoric
yeah Thank You mr. and here we have the
check paid by mr. robot here the
underdog did not prevail but you know we
can't always have you know a thriller
okay let's go deeper into the rabbit
hole see what what's happening here mr.
backward pawns okay that son Gooden good
handle
mr. backward pawns sort of like Edward
Scissorhands only only you know the
chess version would would I ever like to
visit India yes of course I definitely
am planning to visit it best chess book
of all time for intermediate players I
don't know I'm really not not the person
to - well reply to that but I would
imagine 1953 legendary tournament but by
David Bronstein I'm pretty sure with
that book you will learn a lot if you're
an intermediate player I have it and I
started it and but I've only gone
through a few games but the way the way
branch that explains it it's it's
beautiful just you know amazing do I
like Harry Potter no I don't like the
movie and I've only read the first book
I did enjoy the first book probably more
than the movie but I don't know I
haven't read the other ones and I don't
really like the movie who do I think
will win the Magnus Invitational well I
mean probably Magnus but who knows since
its rapid it can be it can be anyone
question is how how good will future
play
if you want the lottery what's the most
expensive chess thing you would do
that's well that's a weird question
yeah Jolly Roger says that Harry Potter
books are worth that much better than
the movies yeah I pretty much got that
from reading only the first book and it
did seem like there's a lot more like in
the book like I've read The Game of
Thrones book at the first book and it's
very very similar to the to the actual
series so even the things they say it's
like they just copy-paste it from the
book when I read Harry Potter it's wood
there was a lot more everything was a
lot more you know in detail so I don't
know how do I prepare my videos well
it's it's a very long and you know and
the tiring process I have to check out
the game and then you know learn about
the game then I have to analyze the game
then I have to figure out what's the
best way to show the game to to everyone
else so they would enjoy it as well
sometimes you have a game that's like
you know first time you see it it's like
really boring and there's nothing to it
but then you when you see it again
there's something that happens that they
get that game that was really really
exciting so you know it's it does take a
while but fastest chess player I don't
know I would guess
I would guess Andrew tang but
do the or Napo for what there are very
few who can who can play against nipple
nipple is an elite player will do that
is also an elite player but I still
think nipple is a little bit you know
higher just him being in the candidates
is pretty much proof of that one player
from past I would like to play with well
of course
pretty much everyone but if one it's
hard hard it would be hard to pick one I
guess it would be fun to face more fee
what is your day job well this this is
my day job as you know it does look a
bit weird but you know someone has to
promote chess is it's a thing
which car do you drive will be seven
going after the rook okay we have a nice
check and queen delivers made very nice
and again we have a victory by the
underdog even if it's only by uh by a
few rating points but very nice
congratulations mister backward pawns I
knew that he would win as soon as I saw
the handle
alright let's go go a bit deeper check
some games
okay there's freedom master call - way
back let's see how he's doing he just
joined he just joined and he's berserk
in so I think he's thinking about maybe
winning the tournament but we'll see how
it goes what other games do you play
ah very very few I do I do
play some hearthstone I do enjoy
battlegrounds and I I enjoyed the new
expansion it's not ok a nice mate or
perhaps made almost rude I admit for
guarded by the bishop very nice yeah I
enjoyed the new hearthstone expansion so
I don't know how long will it last as
they they kind of ruin the game like
almost immediately as soon as they fix
something but we'll see how it goes no I
don't play pop G I should try magic
arena I tried it a friend of mine plays
magic the arena but I I don't know I
know that I realized that it's a much
more complicated game and everything
than hearthstone but since uh I started
with hearthstone I pretty much never
tried any other games well card games
I am 32 years old you [ __ ] ellipses
versus Omega leuf Omega loose this for
the I don't think that's a real name huh
how often are the tournaments the
tournaments are every Friday like the
little one meadows arena will be from 6
know from yeah from 6 to 7 p.m. Central
European Time and then the the normal
one will be from a 7 p.m. to 9 p.m.
Central European Time
[ __ ] couch area there you go man there's
the shoutout I think mayor is here I'm
pretty sure he is yeah he's he's Daryl
just you know doing nothing as usual
we're waiting for his walk he's you know
he can't wait for the stream to end so
we go for a walk but but it's a good
thing you know since I think I would
recreate much less if it weren't for
meadow so I'm very happy that we take
all the walks should a job of be allowed
to enter the candidates ah
it's unfair to him that he's not in the
candidates but it would be unfair to
everyone else if he if they you know
made the tournament invalid and start
over since they everyone else I mean
especially to NATO and Maxime so it's
just one of those moments where there is
no good good to reply but no feed it
feed it made it that way so they're
gonna have to think something about
about that Thank You mr. Noah's Kruger
from Serbia no I'm not alone here's
meadow and Illinois on the upper floor
also playing the tournament we just
checked out her game was quite the game
what tournament
watching it's the Argonaut or Friday
arena I think okay you guys don't see
you guys don't see because it's in the
left and I only show the board but yeah
what if there are genes in this
tournament with Smurfs accounts well we
can only hope
Thanks thanks mr. Yvonne bunch Thank You
Man
do I sing I do sometimes but you know I
don't know if it's if it's like for
people to hear no I don't have a patreon
but I will make patreon as soon as we
launch our chest manga which we are
really working at you know non-stop so
should be published in maybe a month or
two and then we're probably gonna start
patreon to to allow people to support
the idea since it is a bit costly but
we'll see if people enjoy of course no I
don't think there will be prizes for
both tournaments maybe yeah I'm pretty
sure we're only gonna have prizes for
the for the bigger one yeah those of you
who are new to the channel we we are
currently in the process of creating
world's first chest manga I've mentioned
it a few times on the channel but for
those of you or maybe new maybe you
don't know that and yeah we're
definitely gonna start up patreon at
some point to allow and that'sa mate
okay
or you don't want to deliver mate it's a
weird game how did that King get there
that was weird is it not what actually
happened you know I was kind of looking
at the chat and then I spotted the King
on e7 I'm like what that's uh that's a
pretty wild King or maybe the King is
still actually what is this what I'm
just gonna refresh the page so yeah okay
the King is there I had to refresh the
page it was uh it was a bug in the
matrix yeah that was weird and okay we
have a flag off will and it's too slow
if you want to flag someone that's too
slow and there it is
good game mister you [ __ ] ellipses who
again wins as the underdog good game man
okay we have future world champion in
the stream also streaming as he says so
in the comments okay let's go deeper
deeper deeper let's go some some wild
games are lurking here most likely I'll
be from Italy learning to fly ok mister
learning to fly we're gonna check that
one and then we're gonna check up on the
leaders a little bit yeah that was
insane but it was a bug in the in the in
the graphical interface I believe no the
King can do that don't ya that was ok
the meter milk of positive positive wala
can plain just make you a millionaire
yeah definitely definitely it takes
longer I imagined and they play football
but yeah it is possible I think the
first official chess millionaire was
Karpov
I think he's considered the first chess
millionaire which side do I face my
Knights I'm pretty sure like I can't
remember
it's either forward or or inwards like
facing each other or forward huh wow
it's been a while since I've played an
over the board game Morphy vs. tall
versus Fischer I don't know what kind of
a question is that the new haircut is
fabulous thank you thank you I will let
Jelena know over the years my hair color
changed I definitely didn't it's always
been the same color like light brown
yeah nobody plays over the board anymore
but they should i there's nothing like
playing over the board
can we do bullet yeah we're definitely
gonna do some bullet events in the
future but since all of you pretty much
voted that you like 90% of your wallet
for blitz and only 10% voted for bullet
I decided we're gonna go for four blitz
on this one okay
so white will have a very hard time here
oh and good thing it's not made since
the bishop covers it but yeah now white
white is lost here
yeah blitz is better for spectators
huh
how much training does a GM need each
day I have no idea we would have to ask
a grandmaster that okay so now it's a
classic case of two bishops against one
bishop and now we will see how how to
convert such an endgame what's my
favorite word to say when I blunder oh
you don't want to know you don't want to
know it's not a word to share with
someone and now black needs to make some
room for his King
start attacking those Queen side pawns
and that should be it
oh no it's not a draw definitely not a
draw do I curse in creation or English
both obviously will there be a rapid
tournament known unlikely faster time
formats I guess it would be possible to
to make an event for title players since
it's very unlikely that title players
would cheat I mean it would not only
hurt their reputation but also get them
banned but for an open tournament where
everyone can play I don't think we could
go for we could go for a rapid event
learning to fly okay the queen is here
and that's resigned by my love ESCO 27
so we're at the half 1/2 point so an
hour already passed and let's see who is
leading the tournament yeah you moot
crazy who had a had a really long streak
and then lost the final game so let's
let's check one of his games against a
perilous pawn ah how do I show games ten
minutes after the game has already been
played well obviously I analyze it
during the time it's played so by the
time the game finishes I already have it
analyzed I just have to make a video
it's not really not really a difficult
one to to figure out
happy birthday Shawshank and don't don't
spam man and we have a Wow that's a nice
one nice one
good game mr. humid crazy that was so
crazy that I'm inclined to see another
one
bye mister bye mister humid crazy that
was that was very impressive favorite
chess player ever I'm pretty sure to
chat the chat can tell you that like the
dude is pretty much always always right
up here so it's not not really secret
okay makes sense since when bond
captures attacks the bishop
can I please add what can I please add a
five-second slow mode yeah I'm pretty
sure I could I've never actually tried
doing that
yeah I can't do it now while the stream
is active but I will look into it for
the next one yes in the spirit of me
hull tile
yes my favorite player is passkey good
one Ahmed says he played against five
cheaters well that's that's a bad streak
but you know we do have some luck
because as I've requested a hundred
games for you to just be able to play
the tournament those who have cheated
have had their accounts banned and will
well we'll have to go through all the
trouble of playing a hundred more games
to be able to cheat in another
tournament so basically we're doing the
good work here how can you cheat in this
game I don't know but well one way is
obvious you check out the engine for for
recommendations but I don't know how
it's done in faster time formats Thank
You mr. legend since 26 from Scorpia
thanks for the contribution man my
parents my parents also live here not
here obviously but in my hometown quite
close to this place actually like maybe
it's a ten minute walk
okay marker says it will i be a mod on
the next stream automatically or does it
reset no I think the mods remain I'm
pretty sure the mod to remain forever
so far I've always reset them myself
since I didn't know if they were gonna
show up on the next stream but I guess
second I can leave it I mean it doesn't
really it doesn't really hurt
Thank You mr. Elma Dean can't contact me
on an email if you are really interested
yes Ahmed that is very good for for 12
years all right
three points against three points a wild
wild game and white doing better on the
clock against the leader of the
tournament it's gonna be it's gonna be
very exciting to see what happens here
and is the king happy on f4
yeah g5 okay if king g4 okay going for
the trade podcast guests well for now I
have to obviously I'm not gonna reveal
them as of yet but fairly soon as I
imagine
I imagine you guys will have some
questions for them so I'm gonna use your
questions as well
okay Marco if you if you insist I will
leave you as a mod not a problem I will
not be resetting the mods and what's
happening here white is down the rook
but has two pawns and now
okay this is really weird how do you
make progress here it's not gonna be
easy but it is I mean it should be
winning no reason for it not to be
especially with all those pawns
yeah I think black has no options but
the flagon so the only option just memes
in the future
yeah I mean if you guys sent would send
me some chests means I would definitely
store them somewhere and you know save
them for future streams you know I mean
it's a win-win can you pin a question I
don't think you can pin a question oh
it's it's a petition for a garry
kasparov saga plus it would take us for
like forever to finish it so we're gonna
hold up on that and will it be a victory
for the underdog this some know what you
must create won the game but he was up a
rock so I guess it's fair crazy stuff
and we have some title players who also
showed up here at the top gorky pelion
let's see his position well both our end
games over we're gonna check out both of
them oh no here are Queens on the board
and and black is up upon a kramnik saga
well those are all two modern players I
mean until we finish like really older
players not much point in doing casparo
for a chronic saga yes flagging is
winning on time a rama' krishna' we
don't need any more mods for the moment
but you know for the next one definitely
or if if we'll really need to yeah it's
not a problem
threatening the bishop so how do you
deal with this the main threat is there
and if you defend it with Queen then
just
night attacks it so it's gonna be very
hard Queen here huh probably probably
but still night here yeah still night
here
no there's no difference yeah I think
this is oh the games over hahaha I was
looking at the disk lock here very nice
and let's see some other some other guys
here margeeve is also here see some
unrated players my favorite pizza well
as I don't eat meat I don't have all
that many pizzas I can eat that's again
with the rhymes I I'm not doing it on
purpose but like if there's like you
know would I consider streaming Final
Fantasy well no not really i when i
stream i would when i play like a game
like final fantasy where i'm really
interested in the story i really just
want to focus on it and you know soaking
or all the story 95 okay very nice
probably rookie 7 no first that okay
haha followed by rookie 7 and mikey six
maybe whoa okay attacks over now you
have to trade thank you mister merr of
indian obviously obviously a fan of the
matrix
yeah and I got matter saga that would be
a short one but I do have some very
interesting games I am planning to show
from when I started playing chess white
offers a draw black declines a draw of
course I mean you've you're down to 15
seconds you're not gonna get a draw but
you know it's worth to try best book for
beginners I imagine for chess beginner
son well and if you're a beginner and
every book is good I don't think you'll
find a like a bad book or take a David
says I love women that's that's nice man
where is the beer i I don't have any
beer um I haven't prepared beer for this
stream I didn't know if the stream was
gonna last or not but I do have some
water here beer would have been better
made maybe for the next one and again a
victory for the underdog very nice
perilous spawn again wins so what do we
have here freedom master boy blah boy
dia alright let's check out that game
from Mauritania
it's gonna be a nice a nice already what
do you guys play against the red tea do
you have like a favorite system against
the red you just you know mimic white do
you go for d5 do what I play against the
ready all right here a lot of a lot of
space grabbed in the center and now
white will have to do something about
that light square bishop
I just blunder yeah that's one way to
play against the righty he five versus
the ready yes that's my favorite of
course maybe maybe prepared first but
yeah definitely five do I speak German
not not not very well kind good ah FM
played King g7 it was a mouse slip or
was it can i play with subscribers I
Karen but that's for a different stream
I played against I played against one
person here was a really good game well
not by me but but it was a it was a good
game to play f6 that's that's
imaginative yes strong GM versus Agatha
matter that would be maybe maybe some
content like that for for future streams
I haven't tried we can be on burger
burger but I like how it sounds so it
must be must be great
Arthur yeah I already mentioned I've
only tried tried it the the Final
Fantasy remake like for maybe half an
hour today but what I've seen I have
enjoyed alright a lot of a lot of
pressure on the F file so guess that
pawn sacrifice was called 4h for very
nice probably gonna be some characters
on g5 yep and black still needs to get
that Bishop into the game somehow but I
don't think it's easier said and done
why did Carlson Lu lose against fuchsia
because fuchsia played better that's the
true answer ha okay
Phoenix really putting a grip on freedom
masterboy idea
is there going to be something special
for 600k subscribers no like I said III
as we already had like a big big big
event for 500,000 subscribers I thought
maybe maybe we're gonna do another one
maybe at 750 but we're definitely gonna
commemorate it somehow he some no I
don't have any plans on lessons online
just you know preparing that okay nice
nice Queen grab I think black does have
a material and that passed pawn however
with that King there I don't think it's
it's gonna be possible to pull this off
why I give up the rook
I guess he's hoping that he didn't see
it yeah he didn't see it ha but he
doesn't need to see it I mean he has a
queen what percentage of a god we see on
youtube is the real life Agata I would
imagine 100% although I could be wrong I
am pretty sure everyone would say that
but I I kind of hope I hope it is
Alexander idea he asks how can I be
Grand Master it's chess well you just
have to you just have to get really good
and then win a lot of games against some
very strong people across the 2500
threshold and then of course get your
norms and that's it that's all you need
to do and now black will put those pawns
Wow check here check nope okay Wow
and now wife just says I don't care
good game by the Phoenix 67 another
great win by the underdog really
enjoying those so let's let's go a bit
deeper
let's see where where we're going next
Olympic okay
seems reasonable yes I did say I love
salmon and I'm vegetarian but we make we
make vegan Sarma so it also works well
you know regardless of what at what
everyone says it's delicious
suggest a book to improve I don't know
which books need improving now but
seriously uh depending on depending on
your level yeah it's actually super
funny to me how how a lot of you call
meadow actually meadow like like you
know someone someone wrote it here M e
ad o W it's actually not metal but it is
very cute when you say like that
and we have a pawn endgame where white
is clearly better unless he's not and
yes he is yeah that's it f4 is coming
and that's that's just it
how is quarantine I'm guessing pretty
much the same as as it is for you guys
not not the greatest
do a play enjoy poker well I enjoy it
much more than I play it but I was
thinking maybe like these days I should
play like maybe a tournament or
something to get back get back into the
inter game okay it's actually not that
bad not so many people are spamming it's
way worse it usually it's way worse but
okay we're here we don't have a win by
the underdog but good game by both
players so let's start going a little
bit deeper
okay here we had someone YouTube I have
seen someone or maybe also streaming
maybe I just imagined it okay let's
check out unbreakable one more game
against ilya klebanov alright rooks
unopened files very nice okay yeah this
is gonna be a good one
do I like Veselin Topalov well I know
how much I can like someone but IIIi
know he's okay yeah I was I was a
vegetarian for a very long time like for
maybe 15 years maybe even 16 but now now
I'm vegan
yeah the game against Indian comedians
was was quite quite the game
yeah don't never stop playing chess man
is made of the price for the meadow
tournament you mean the the password no
it we're not gonna have passwords for
these these ones huh
what to do what to do where to break
through yep that's for that's for them
to to decide we're just gonna we're just
gonna enjoy our job of saga yeah he's a
bit too young especially now that he's
fully back in playing chess the
quarantine gambit yeah we should really
make one one of those
do you guys know know what the Borg
defense is have you heard of the Borg
defense I've seen mr. beast made a video
visiting some sort of a nuclear shelter
and they were playing chess inside and
he played against his I think he's a
video editor and he went for the for the
Borg defence was a quite quite the
opening okay we actually have people
playing Borg defense nice
and we have a loss by unbreakable a nice
win by Illya Glee Gaurav it was a yeah a
nice check and once the King moves yeah
that's that's it so let's continue our
tournament let's see how are we doing at
the top still leading by umid crazy from
Turkey and we have alpha zero three six
nine who is usually playing in our
events so let's check out a game by
alpha zero
well I quickly run for a nice glass of
water
[Music]
all right we're back how is office you
are doing against the Jonas zmb why I
didn't take beer well I don't have any
beer that's that's a shame I know but it
is as it is d4 or efore well I've always
played e4 but I've been having some
thoughts lately of maybe I should try
playing some d4 maybe we'll see how it
goes maybe some some London system and
stuff yeah the Dogo is here he's always
here am i excited about the magnus
invitational yes I am I mean in these
days of of lockdown having such an event
is is more than more than well you know
with the candidates being adjourned
well postponed definitely we should have
something and this is quite the event
for rapid games every day against such
top elite players really gonna be
awesome
pretty yes I can reply but I have not
seen your question man my favourite
defense against d4 I don't know what my
favorite defense is but I mostly played
the nimzo-indian says it just makes
sense for black it just makes sense yeah
maybe still here he's not going anywhere
well most of the times sometimes he's
just sleeping under the table
captures new okay
I was I was yeah okay you can't because
of the bishop but now Bishop D for makes
sense I guess
no it doesn't capture us and there goes
the rook yeah that's resigns good game
off of 0 good game that was a very nice
tactic alright let's go to some other
page [ __ ] parcel let's see what's
happening here
Oh against Ronaldinho wow I can't
believe I I accidently chose the game
that Ronaldinho is playing because they
chose the game by horace jorge Paxil and
then he's playing against Ronaldinho
very nice let's see how Colonel Dino
plays this with black what is the price
of winning this tournament well for this
tournament the price is well as usual
bragging rights and you also get a
shout-out on my social media which is
not much of a prize but it's what we
have for this one
mm yeah that's basically what Ronaldinho
means this is actually not a gaming
chair this is a like a normal chair
what is the chest etiquette for
trash-talking it's with more than
welcome to K more to K more for what I
imagine for a for 600 K okay poxy is
very long time but that's normal when
you play against Ronaldinho he's like
hip he moves instantly okay epic game
good game groaning Oh a nice win and we
have Bruno let's see how Bruno is doing
everyone's almost at the top
all right Bruno oh that's nasty
you can't capture because of checkmate
so King moves you lose the rook or do
you ha what threats does crew Bruno have
probably probably at some point this
opening up the bishops diagonal and
moving the knight would result in a
what's this can you just open it up or
not I guess no Bruno knows best
yeah mr. classified info this is live
and now now white is down upon without a
clear idea of how to know down a piece
and I think Bruno will just well we win
this quite easily
I imagine yeah he goes for a queen trade
as you should when you're up material of
course white white is not interested
how is corona outbreak in creo they very
manageable I think we are I don't even
know we're at like 1500 confirmed cases
something like that but it's still a
linear growth so not really not really
struggling struggling it as far as I
know it's to plus in Asia to plus what I
am
thanks mr. Restrepo but this is hardly
hardly the stream for for such stories
okay there we go man here's a high-five
for you there we go
have to be careful not not to knock down
my camera okay Bruno are you winning
this or not well what are you doing
those bishops of white are looking very
nasty so I guess I guess you wanna
capture on g6 but if I don't since
you're down material so it's not not
easy and here we have resins very nice
and Bruno wins against the leader
congratulations Bruno taking down the
leader of the tournament but also yeah
he really did he really crashed his
streak he had like eight games winning
streak and then Bruno took him down so
Bruno is Bruno means business let's
check out another game of Bruno's who is
a knight see two against the Sicilian
player as you can see
huh will another one start in 30 minutes
no no we only have the two it would be
too much I don't know I'm not like some
some some people who stream like they
can stream for like 15 hours some I've
seen some stream for 24 hours I'm like
more of a three hours stream kind of guy
maybe for like if it's if it's a duo
with Yann Almighty or something like
that but it's it's you know hard work
what am I going to do for 600,000
subscribers what do you suggest I do I
mean the we could do a lot I didn't I
actually didn't have anything planned
out as like I said I was only planning
on doing like maybe 750 K but I don't
know what to rank my English is I've
never had it like officially tested or
something no I will not be streaming
Final Fantasy like I said that's that's
just for me
[Music]
oh these are some heavy games for a
three plus oh do I like grease yeah like
grease I've been once but I've been once
but it was a long time ago like maybe 14
years ago he I think was 14 years ago
like like a field trip with my high
school make a room tour for 600k well
there is no not much to do for a tour
this is the room that's it
well yeah quarantine is not the greatest
but you know if you enjoy chess you're
better off than most people who like if
you're if you're exclusively an outdoors
person then you know it's probably it's
probably terrible but if you're you're
also an indoor it kind of guy maybe
enjoy some chests on games then it's a
more manageable a giveaway of chests box
with chess pieces yeah I've used to do
that like all the time before but it was
really a hassle so I don't know it seems
like it's way easier to do like sort of
a Amazon gift card giveaway or some like
that since there's always problem with
the shipping of the board and yeah I
like that
Bruno Bruno how will this all work out I
like the pawn on f6 I like the knight so
it's only a matter of time before Bruno
wins this how exactly will he do it
we'll have to see and what will black do
probably Bishop g4 is blacks next move
getting that Bishop into the game nope
he offers a queen trade he's a long time
he has to find something wow this is
this is crazy stuff have you ever been
to Albania nope nope I haven't of course
black declines but he spent a lot of
time on it he doesn't want to blunder
with some black yeah okay there's no way
to put your queen somewhere for the
night to attack it who would I have
liked playing the Magnus Invitational
well I think they they chose the right
people those are all pretty much young
people who are used to playing fast time
formats online and I think it's a good
event especially with Fallujah and
Hikaru you know they're gonna be going
to be a wild event
how to get over 1500 well I imagine just
studied the endgame a bit more and bruna
blunders ah
how will he recover Ruka for 2h 4 I
imagined yeah
what black will just trade Oh
and Bruno runs runs into mate
oh no Bruno it was it was good while it
lasted
and alpha zero takes the lead nice ahead
of Gorky Polina and humid humid crazy
and now Gorky pauline takes the lead
with his berserk king streak very nice
yeah what a sneaky mate alright let's
check out another bye bye Gorky Pelin
but he's not playing currently so let's
check out Ronaldinho he's in the top ten
what what a guy oh he's against Bruno
what what luck are incredible Bruno
Bruno is a very strong player from from
Zagreb very strong dude yeah what's the
word are the chances some matchmaking
all right
huh I know off been Feingold I don't
know him personally no Colonel Dean is
playing black Bruno's with the white
pieces do I think talents is prime could
beat Magnus
I think talent his prime could be anyone
if he learned the modern theory of
course first ha
who will trick who here both players
with background weaknesses but it's a
bit harder for Colonel Dino but Bruno
berserk him oh that's this very brave
berserk Inc Ronaldinho as he is
extremely fast
I think Bruno will learn this the hard
way or maybe he won't
wow what a blunder by Bruno it's not a
big blunder it's a pawn but still who is
the special guest you I still cannot
reveal but like I said I'm not stopping
you from trying to guess how long have
Jelena and I've been together almost
almost 10 years no Bruno is not the
special guest and Bruno resigns yes that
will teach you never to berserk
Ronaldinho he's like the fastest player
I know he's like you know supersonic
when it comes to chess all right let's
see how our leader is doing mr. Gore
keep a lean now on each Giri is not on
each year is not the guest although he
might be interested in some future
future podcasts maybe or maybe he is
well you know you never know
well I prefer commentary in life
candidate or Linares ha it's hard hard
to say and the Gorky Pelin losses from
Lane from wired there you have it
you can't win them all that that ruins
his streak a bit but ok he had a Burger
King streak so I imagine he will you
know get it right back but alpha zero
again on a pretty great streak and we
don't have anyone currently in a non
losing streak ok we have oh wow coach
genius here won all the games and then
he just stopped playing ok and we have
Magnum also winning all pretty much all
games but then stopping to play ok let's
just go here see how mister whatever how
do you pronounce that
aku Nene against again against poxy Wow
his honor root of the guest I don't know
could be could be
when is the podcast the podcast is
between 28th 12th of May and 20th in May
20th yeah we can see another game of L&S
but she's currently not playing I think
she's talking on the phone at the moment
could Murphy beat Magnus by after
learning modern theory no one no one no
one can you know say that for sure as
Magnus is not only good because he
learned modernity theory Magnus is also
an incredible player but no one actually
knows how strong Morpheus or how strong
he would have become if he needed to
yeah this is just bad for for black
he would need a lot of practice after
after he learned all the theory to even
to even be able to to survive the
opening he car watched the video of
agamotto best moments okay that's that's
not the not the worst way how you can
spend your time okay
captures and then the King runs away
black will still try and play this and
he should you never know
thoughts on Jerry from chest network
yeah Jerry's an awesome guy his videos
are awesome I've seen a few of his
streams I I do enjoy his commentary
during during his play but even just
commentary on the games that he does is
great so all the best of Jerry and
that's it Queen g5 is mate so boxy again
with the win Wow very nice against an
incredibly strong player okay what do we
have here
how's the situation at the top so
everyone wins some losses some and we
are down to the last twenty minutes of
the tournament so let's let's go deeper
like I said into the rabbit hole squishy
how is our good friend squishy doing
let's okay but we already seen again by
squishy
let's HS okay let's check a game by HS
HSB
yeah morphe would be very good in short
time formats I am getting back into
playing guitar I don't play it last time
I played it like regularly was now I
don't know 1718 years ago
do you think we will learn a lot of new
things if Lila were to play against
alpha0 I don't think we would learn new
things but I'm sure we would have a have
a great time what is good on Netflix I
don't know we're watching the blacklist
at the moment but other than that I
don't know you tell me what's good yeah
Hikaru Magnus tomorrow that's we can
definitely expect that one to be to be
great but as they're playing for games
it's gonna be hard to choose what the
cover I'm gonna have my work cut out for
me yeah money highest I've seen everyone
[Music]
talking about that and Bojack horseman
yeah I've seen I've seen some episodes
seems seemed very nice but I didn't I
didn't continue yeah Ozark I've seen
also a few episodes of Ozark but didn't
continue yeah I mean we could start
tournaments a little bit later and we
also could start a little bit sooner but
however I I put it you know we can't
accommodate everyone unfortunately yeah
okay Rick and Morty obviously uh Rick
and Morty I've seen Rick and Morty yeah
Breaking Bad just I just lost interest
at some point I think it was around
season five now started being a little
bit boring for me and peaky blinders
seems very interesting but I didn't get
get the chance to watch it I've only
seen the first episode and it seemed it
seemed very nice yeah better call Saul
Saul is actually a lawyer from another
episode or like from or is he from
Arrested Development
the lawyer Saul and then he got his own
show I think
who is better Fabio he karo well raiding
why's the fob is better in classical but
he car is better at faster time formats
I think I think he's definitely better
in blitz in rapid I I would still I
would still say Fabi
we won more games
ah stole his blower from Breaking Bad
why did I think he was a lawyer from
Arrested Development huh yeah yeah do I
work out regularly no but I I wish I did
i I I'm constantly playing on planning
on starting to work out regularly but I
just don't as I find better things to do
like many other people but I hope I will
start at some point to do it regularly
yes he Carl will play a Carlson's
tournament yeah well the strongest
player in Croatia I believe is even
Charlotte sure even though the the
creation championship was won by Martin
Bostick
but even it's still high rated and I
think you know to be strongest but
Martin is also incredibly strong and
here we have another win not by the
underdog engine oh seven nine one wins
and we go into the final 13 minutes okay
let's go a bit deeper who we have here
ah we have future world champion who
said he was also streaming so let's
check out one of his games against the
attack Titian as part of our Karpov
that's those are you know two sides of
the same coin you can't have one without
the other one is the the absolute
positional master against the absolute
master of everything else it's like when
you combine two of them you get chess
yeah it does look like college my
favorite player no I can't show my dog
any closer since made of chooses where
where he goes I can't really force him
to do that like maybe if he decided to
come all the way to the camera although
I doubt he will do that and what do we
have here obviously black is completely
winning so good game mr. future world
champion if he ever becomes future world
champion we will be very nice that at
some point he played he played in other
matters Friday tournaments all right how
is the situation
okay let's we still have time so few
more games here and then we go to the
top let's see dreamchaser yeah seems
like okay we lost not he's here
dreamchaser let's check out dreamchaser
against the mic and bike now that's a
good handle if you've ever needed a good
handle mic and bike that's the stuff why
is it showing zero people in the chat I
don't know III don't think it's zero
people in the chat best final fantasy of
course 7 then 8 then 9 then 10 it's like
further you go the words they are
alright dreamchaser F 3 kicks away the
best shop and I guess you trade here or
no you don't really care since you have
the rook better get the other night
inter game maybe yeah maybe or that
yeah okay nice nice but how do you
continue with Ian
yeah but that one game Fisher played
against both meaning that is what a
masterpiece and how Fisher surprised
them with you know basically in the
opening it's incredible that the bottom
Enoch was unaware of that but we need to
know everything and Fisher still
surprises him in the opening h6 ok very
nice let's see how Mike and bike deals
with this I've never taken an online
chess course no I've never done that
Anderson or Morphy well we will soon
reach that and it's gonna be it's gonna
be quite a it's gonna be great moves the
bishop and now
hmm I guess you push h7 at some point I
I do not have a favorite classical
composer thank you I'm very glad you
guys are enjoying the morphe saga check
and we have well white is clearly doing
all the pushing here black has a weird
night on a6 and still needs to get that
rock into a game and white is hoping to
do something about the past pawn on h7
probably get the other night into the
game and harass this rook even further
caro-kann or the Sicilian I don't play
either although I am planning to start
playing the Sicilian so I guess the
Sicilian who am I expecting to win the
candidates I'm not expecting anyone and
we still have to see how it will
continue but I don't know
even though ok currently in VL and nip
are leading but I still haven't written
ding out of the tournament
like I know it's a big big deficit to
start with with so many losses but I
don't know hi to Albania thoughts on a
job of well it's it's hard to say I mean
that's really one of the weirder
situations that happened what the job
was right fee they handled it poorly in
my opinion but now that the decision
situation is as it is and they had to
cancel it anyway I don't know there was
this very interesting idea of letting or
a job of play or before the can
it's continued like having him play
online against everyone else with
arbiters of course being present at each
location and then after the he plays
against everyone then we just continue
the candidates with nine players instead
of eight so that pretty much I guess
makes everyone happy but it is you know
it would be unprecedented can we also
make a bullet on Friday I will see and
we have a nice game one on time so treat
dreamchaser wins on time as the underdog
so sorry mr. Mike and Mike and we go we
go for the six more minutes so let's
check out our leaders and titles players
have taken up all the spots at the top
mr. Feeley master called ash and freedom
masterwork appellant so let's see how
they are doing 94 to 89 I don't think
and both of them with hot streaks
so if called ash wins this one I think
that we have our winner and he lost he
got checkmated okay spoke too soon
so maybe our friend Gorky pelion has a
chance here to catch up to him up
against generators but I guess everyone
is tense now he also loses to a severe
underdog but he did berserk so shame for
everyone and everyone offer zero also
lost after his incredible streak who
else is trying to catch up to them it
will be hard to catch up to these three
guys as they are doing so well where did
Colonel Dino go the here are Bruno and
Ronaldinho are trying but you know the
hot D the more the wind the stronger the
opponents and then it's just hard but
you know that's how tournaments work
okay another game by the leader let's
check it out I think we have time for
two more games and
using the players yeah hmm did I watch
Luke okay again call - wins against
alpha zero wow those guys are super fast
I can't even can't even get a game in so
offers you are just lost and now a you
empty crazy might be able to catch up to
offer zero but very unlikely and three
players with with the streak so who
knows how fast they can play okay now
again from the beginning by the leader
against poxy and he berserk him so we'll
see how it goes
Thank You mr. samurai gaming thanks for
the contribution who will challenge
Carlsen for the title whoever wins the
candidates everyone is hoping it's going
to be nipple and it would be quite quite
good if it was cross and versus nipple
no I have not watched Tiger King do i
watch coffee chest I've seen maybe three
or four videos but it's always
interesting they always find this you
know some some someone new to play
against there their lineup yeah I was I
was kind of planning on doing a cup of
saga if you guys voted Karpov but it was
basically either eater car pool or you
did polgár or Paul Morphy
but in the end most of you decided that
it was time for more fish saga so that's
what we're doing so here we have a nice
pawn grab that black Queen and c8 not
all that impressive we'll see we'll see
how it goes I Akiba rubenstein saga
definitely a saga
to be promoted in the future good old
Akiba yeah I learned chess very young
and like at the age of four or five but
then I didn't play until I was like I
don't know 16 yeah ding it's it's pretty
weird that ding lost so many games in
the candidates but he just you know if
it's not your tournament it's not your
tournament doesn't matter how strong you
are no we haven't done the audience saga
we will at some point of course it's a
natural continuation to the capablanca
saga but there's time I don't plan on
stopping making videos anytime soon so
best game of off of the magician whoa
that's there are too many to choose from
too many to choose from and what have we
here foxy doing good work by keeping up
with Kalash on time but he is very very
fast limiting the mobility of that night
and now he has to give up a pawn and now
I don't think black will be able to do
anything that Bishop on g5 is a monster
yeah I don't think this is playable
anymore now the b7 pawn Falls oh he
doesn't even want it okay so he wants to
improve the position of the King makes
sense now I guess just rook check trade
rooks and you're winning he doesn't even
want okay now now he goes for it
yeah but it's bishops of opposite color
so you have to be careful not to be
tricked but I don't think there's much
you can do yeah there's nothing you can
do
thanks mister shipp inator all right we
are down to the last 43 seconds so we
can check out if there are any more
games a hundred points for for freedom
master college 90 from Poland 2800
bullet rating wow that's impressive and
thank you Jerry MacDonald for the
contribution thanks a lot man I don't
think you'll be playing any more games
and it's not possible to to get any more
games in I think if there's less than 20
seconds for the tournament
ah Carlos Ruiz Carmelita okay
I did not know that okay and that that's
it for the tournament although we're
gonna wait a few more seconds for all
the games to finish and then if there is
no funny business that should that
should be it so we're just gonna like
wait for for a minute or so and I think
we can we can start announcing some
winners
[Music]
so we've reached the end of the first
target matter Friday arena and the
winners are
fede master called us 90 who someone
mentioned was coming up lista but I can
check that out yeah it is him
Carmelita so good of you to join us in
this tournament then we have a feedom
master Gorky pauline in second place and
in no sorry in second place it's alpha
zero who is a common attend drove of
these tournaments and then in third
place video master Gorky Pauline so
congratulations to you guys for winning
the tournament and we have in fourth
place you must create a th for for one
and fifth Jonas s ZM be from Poland in
sixth Jorge poxy in seventh future Grand
Master - in eight we have Sankey 95 in
9th and intent we have AG neva
from India and we're also gonna check
out some other guys we have a sickness
gaming in 11th killin K in 12 EXPEED in
13 a solid crazy in 14th and pipa people
took the partook in 15 economy 16 pop
attack in 17th mr. dad nobody in 18th
naval chess in 19th and Ronaldinho in 20
congratulations Ronaldinho on such a
such a strong tournament I think he
berserk like every game he's crazy dude
but here 28 out of 2600 players that's
quite an achievement and our good friend
Bruno is in 22nd just gonna raw and
golden chest lab also plays from Zagreb
very nice in 29th place congratulations
man good good achievement we have
awesome that's like a sausage without an
s Johnny in 25th Phoenix 67 we've seen
some great games by Phoenix at 23rd Lane
from wired we also seen a nice victory
by him AJ good a one in 21st and well in
30th dev - 2006 so like I said like a
for the previous tournament the most
gonna publish the winners of this
tournament on my social media pages so
be sure to congratulate everyone because
it's always nice to always nice to
congratulate the winners you know it is
the least we can do so yeah that's
pretty much it for this one and yeah
glad glad you guys could make it
thank you all for joining it was a
wonderful tournament in the first one in
the sub 700 arena we had almost 2,000
players and here we had 2625 players so
not not a bad another bad number for our
tournament with no prizes but like I
said prizes are bragging rights plus you
get a nice shout-out on my social media
which isn't much I know but for the
first one it is it is what it is so yeah
that's it for this one it's the same in
the next Friday
so first metals arena for our sub 700
players and then we we tackle the the
main event again 2 hours of some Sun
blitz action so we're gonna see we're
gonna see how it goes
Thank You mr. Tyler Ross for the
contribution he says 540 third place
thanks for the tournament really enjoyed
it thank you and good place considering
how many players there was yeah yeah
that's it guys
thank you for everything if you haven't
seen today's video a Lilla brilliant
positional a game against rockfish go
check it out
other than that see you guys soon
tomorrow with some more videos and the
next Friday again with the same two
tournaments thank you all I will see you
soon and well that's that's it for this
stream enjoy guys